the twilight zone is coming back in this  time it's not a mediocre reboot with  Forest Whitaker i'm tony and this  gamespot news update comes with a twist  the pilot for the new show will be  written and directed by ken Levine the  mastermind behind Bioshock the new  twilight zone is meant to sort of  combine television with gaming and a  choose your own adventure style the  quote interactive project will give  viewers the opportunity to change the  direction of each episode and you can  rewatch to see the story play out in  different ways as of now there's no word  on when the show will premiere Rod  Serling's Twilight Zone originally ran  from nineteen fifty nine to nineteen  sixty-four and the latest reboot sounds  promising in the meantime ken Levine's  team will continue to work on their  secret unannounced game when we hear  more about the twilight zone or that  upcoming game will tell you all about it  on gamespot